sergueï lavrov recevait aujourd'hui à
moscou son homologue libyen du
gouvernement d'union nationale alors que
le pays est toujours profondément
divisée avec de l'autre côté les forces
de l'armée nationale libyenne du
maréchal haftar qui elles tiennent l'est
du pays
les deux hommes ont souligné la
nécessité de capitaliser sur le
cessez-le-feu du 23 octobre dernier et
de favoriser le dialogue entre les deux
parties
je vous propose d'écouter les deux
ministres je suis d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut actuellement encourager
pleinement le dialogue entre les parties
il déjouer les tentatives de discours
belliqueux et surtout les menaces de
reprise des hostilités
nous avons notamment discuté de
l'importance d'assurer la protection de
la population civile de maintenir le
régime
bien que fragile mais existant de cessez
le feu c'est également une
responsabilité du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu l'onu justement qui peine à
imposer sa médiation dans le pays alors
que le chef de la mission d'appui des
nations unies en libye le diplomate
bulgare nikolay mladenov a renoncé à sa
mission laissons donc le poste vacant
alors bien sûr il existe une volonté de
la communauté internationale de
stabiliser la situation dans ce pays
stratégique
plaque tournante de l'immigration
illégale vers l'europe
même si la presse sergueï lavrov la
situation actuelle est la conséquence
directe des actions de certains de ces
pays lors de l'intervention de l'otan en
2011 cela étant je pense que la
communauté internationale cherche bien
sûr à aider les peuples de cette région
à sortir des crises
elle cherche à trouver des accords et à
surmonter les conséquences de la
politique irréfléchie de l'otan et de
ses alliés
l'objectif de ces prochaines semaines et
de ces prochains mois sera donc de
travailler au respect du cessez-le-feu
en vigueur qui peut paraître bien
fragile à entendre les prises de paroles
parfois belliqueuses des responsables
politiques des deux côtés une
stabilisation de la situation qui
conditionnera largement le bon
déroulement des élections présidentielle
et législatives prévues en décembre de
l'année prochaine